boys town is now looking to hire as it  grows within ccsd the program has a long  history of helping students here in  southern nevada with their struggles at  home at school and just in life it has  served more than 6 600 children in the  past year alone and it looks to support  even more as it expands from 28 to 65  schools  we work with kids specifically to teach  them social skills on how to  get along with each other how to get  along with their teachers how to get  along with administrators and we're  finding that to be more important than  ever right now  boys town is hosting a job fair now at  the address right there on your screen  it runs until seven o'clock tonight uh  just a little bit more time left here  there's also going to be one though  tomorrow from 11 to 3.